I think pushing yourself physically is
the number one factor of life so other
than the five-second rule
there is one habit that I have adopted
in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person there's this reticular activating
system in our brains right and all of a
sudden because that's the messaging I
was giving myself all of a sudden all
these things start to come into my
awareness that I'm grateful for want to
be happy build a life not just a
business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the three habits that the
1% use every day
enjoy okay let's kick it off with habit
number one push yourself physically with
David Goggins
I think pushing yourself physically is
the number one factor of life that is
the true spot where you can really dive
deep into life's about self-discipline
it is about self-discipline we tend to
do the things that are easy and that is
the it builds no mental toughness if
there's no mental hardening it builds
nothing when you work out working out is
where you can build that the fastest
because it's a constant it gives you
instant feedback it's it yeah you may
not lose the weight you want to real
fast but the discipline it takes it
transfers over to all aspects of your
life it's not people man why are you
always working out stop stop looking at
that way this is the foundation of life
when you look in the mirror every
morning we all look in the mirror to get
ready to go to work to go anywhere the
first thing you see is your reflection
if you don't like what you see in the
morning you lost the war already it's
not even liking what you see it's about
looking in mirror and you may start meh
I feel different that reflection maybe
that that reflex is not everything
it's a feeling you're supposed to get so
you have to in life once you leave your
house the war begins in your house you
have some control and that reflects in
that mirror you have to control that
reflection in the mirror that's how you
start your day leave your house feeling
like okay I can fight I've established
the mentality to fight and that all that
comes from working out it's not just
from you know you can't find that in the
office how about number two get rid of
your phone with Mel Robbins so other
than the five-second rule there is one
habit that I have
adopted in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person and it has also changed my
ability to manage my emotions so I don't
get hijacked I do not allow my phone in
the bedrooms I know the research
Deloitte just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33% of people are reading
emails in the middle of the night I know
that if you go to bed and the phone is
right next to you
right so you go to bed because you need
your phone you know somebody might need
you and you sleep you know if this is
right here and it's not closed and the
blue light is on they've done studies
where they have people in a table and
the researcher will put their phone on
the table not even my phone the
researchers phone and the brain lights
up like crazy just with the presence of
a phone the research around the phone
and sleep is so stunning that if you
were to adopt one radical thing today
other than the five-second rule try
putting your phone outside your bedroom
turn off the bit little bit so you don't
hear it tell people who need to reach
you to call you my kids I had a kid in
college a kid who's you know high school
kid in middle school if there's an
emergency call me there is nothing
happening on your phone at two o'clock
in the morning that's important but if
you allow yourself to become a tool of
this this is supposed to be your tool
for selling your tool for communicating
and we're all becoming the tool here's
the other thing common sense why's that
I want you to understand you wake up the
alarm goes off what do you do so you're
not even vertical and you're reading
emails
and what is in these emails other
people's crap but you don't have
boundaries with this puppy it's gonna
impact sleep it's gonna affect how much
money money it's going to connect to
myself controlling half and so whenever
I put this thing outside the bedroom and
I wake up I walk over where the phone is
it's plugged into my bathroom I turn it
off I don't look at it again I give
myself five minutes five minutes before
I tune into the world it's actually
tuned in up here and say what's the one
thing I'm gonna get done today that
really matters to me if you're the kind
of person that feels like you don't have
control over your day make your day gets
hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball
this one planning thing will change your
life no phone in the bedroom turn it off
when the alarm goes off five minutes
five lousy minutes five thousand minutes
before you tune into the rest of the
world and if you've got the kind of job
where you've got to check it get up ten
minutes earlier you have control over
this stuff and it is so important that
you take it seriously now because you're
living at the slowest moment of your
entire life also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
it's free the link to join is in the
description below everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today you might want to get honest
with yourself like instead of doing this
be a millionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make honey
the minute you begin to get external in
your life worrying about what other
people think about you right you vote
you've lost all control you and it never
fills you up and habit number three the
last one before very special bonus clip
is practice gratitude with Edie Mindlin
I had a really good friend of mine I
went to lunch and he said yeah I don't
know who this guy is here in front of me
and he goes let me ask you a question
honestly right now what are you grateful
for and at the lunch I said jack nothing
brother there's nothing good in my life
right now
and I'm not exaggerating this to you
when I tell you this and this is a
factual story as I'm mouthing these
words two people walked in with an older
man both of them clearly were fighting
cancer somehow both had lost their hair
one of the ladies had a bonnet
and they were barely moving in both
walked by our table and gave me the most
warm greeting the warmest smile as a
stranger and he goes that's pretty
freaking pathetic you can't find
anything in your life to be grateful for
right now and on the drive home I'm not
kidding you I started to stack gratitude
I started to take inventory because if
you can find things to be grateful for
in that space man is your life gonna be
rich when there really are external
things to be grateful for
so my first mechanism out of that space
was honestly to stack the things I was
grateful for and I started reinforcing
it over and over and over again and what
happens is there's this reticular
activating system in our brains right
and all of a sudden because that's the
messaging I was giving myself all of a
sudden all these things start to come
into my awareness that I'm grateful for
I start to magnetized to myself some
people that I needed to find into my
life and that was the next layer I
started to see things to be grateful for
my health my fitness people who loved me
and what it did is it changed my state
when I stacked gratitude I changed what
I did in the morning and I changed what
I did in the evening and so somehow by
grabbing control of my morning and by
grabbing control of my evening I got
some measure of control over the middle
of my day I was an out of control person
back in those days meaning this I woke
up worried stressed fearful and I
immediately start thinking about a bill
I had to pay something that was wrong
and I'm in a state of reaction to begin
every sound talking within six minutes
of waking up six seconds most people
listening to this that's what they do I
said I got to grab control of my morning
and I set up routines
in my morning maybe they serve me maybe
they didn't but they were things I could
deliver on doing for myself and so not
only did that give me control over the
day but I started to stack my
self-confidence too now there are
special bonus Kip on how to enhance the
quality of your sleep with rich role
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question of one how
will you push yourself physically today
number two how will you get rid of your
phone today and number three how will
you practice gratitude today
rich why do you sleep in a tent for
those that don't know for the last two
years I've been sleeping outside in this
thing a lot of people have been asking
me why do you do that and it basically
boils down to three fundamental reasons
the first is I just sleep better in a
tent outside the second reason is that
it really has helped me connect with
nature and the outdoors and I think our
primal disposition and the third reason
I've been doing it is because
fundamentally it's a stoic practice a
couple years ago I started struggling
with trying to get a deep sleep unless I
was training SuperDuper hard I just
found it difficult to get the
restfulness that my body and my mind
need and at the time our bedroom that I
share with my wife Julie was either too
cold for her or too hot for me then I
had an experience where we as a family
all slept on our roof one night we have
a flat roof and we did it just for fun
with the kids
and I had the most restful peaceful
night of sleep in recent memory being
outdoors breathing that outdoor air
sleeping under the stars is a very
simple and basic way of reconnecting
with what it means to be fundamentally
human we live in this super fast-paced
culture you got to get your hustle on
you got to like work 24 hours a day and
if you're not being productive in every
moment of your waking existence then
you're wasting time and you're falling
behind and with that comes a deep
prioritization of sleep sleep is for
slackers right and nothing could be
further from the truth I know that I
can't perform a my very best unless I
get eight hours of sleep and it's not
just the amount of time that I sleep
it's the quality of that sleep it's the
caliber of that sleep it is my opinion
that everybody should be doing
everything they can to enhance that
quality of their
evening hours and I found that by
sleeping in a tent it's almost like this
hack towards improving the caliber of my
sleep so that I can show up throughout
my day and Excel be totally focused be
totally present have good energy be in a
good mood and all of that derives from
sleep so if you really take the time to
prioritize the quality and the amount of
time that you're sleeping every night
you will realize quantum gains in your
productivity in your output throughout
your day
if you want to know the 10 skills that
you must learn check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do is whether you like it or not
get very comfortable